اول الواصلين كان المنتخب الامريكي الذي
حلف العاصمه القطريه في العاشر من هذا
الشهر وذلك لمنح لاعبه وقتا كافيا
للتاقلمي مع اجواء البلد المضيف
ووصل المنتخب الايراني مع مدربه المخضرم
كارلوس كيروش ومهاجم بورتو البرتغالي مهدي
تيريمي وزملائه بهدف التاهل من مجموعه
صعبه
منتخب اسيوي اخر وصل الى الدوحه هو
المنتخب الاسترالي وتنتظره مواجهه صعبه في
المجموعه الرابعه امام فرنسا وتونس
والدنمارك
نجم نادي توتنهام الانجليزيه بار جيسون
كان على راس فريق بلاده كوريا الجنوبيه
وعينه على تكرار نتيجه جيده تضاف للنتيجه
التاريخيه التي حققها المنتخب في مونديال
عام 2002
اما منتخب السنغال فحط الرحاله في الدوحه
دون نجم بايرن ميونخ ساديو ماني الذي تعرض
لاصابه اجبرته على اجراء فحوصات
ستحددون نتيجتها امكانيه مشاركته في
المباريات الاولى لاسود الترنجه في
البطوله